[Musique]
il y a beaucoup de facteurs
on dit souvent qu'on est le dernier
Festival de l'été le festival avant la
rentrée il y a une énergie un peu
particulière
c'est la veille de la rentrée des
classes c'est le retour des vacances
pour certains il y a aussi je pense un
un cadre très bucolique particulier ce
parc est quand même incroyable chargé
d'histoire c'est l'idée impressionnistes
il y a c'est vraiment un cadre
incroyable où on se sent pas vraiment en
Île-de-France ou à Paris on est un peu
transporté dans un cadre éthique et je
pense que c'est aussi tout ça qui
participe il y a aussi évidemment notre
public qui est formidable qui joue le
jeu et qui a une énergie folle qui vient
qui vient avec des déguisements
différents on fait un concours de
déguisement chaque année il y a une il y
a vraiment beaucoup de facteurs qui
participent à ça et je pense qu'il y a
aussi voilà la rencontre d'artistes qui
sont vraiment excité de venir faire un
des derniers festivals de l'été avec un
public qui a vraiment envie d'en
découdre
[Musique]
on a quelques petites nouveautés
où on rajoute on rajoute quelques scènes
et After Party donc il y aura le samedi
quelques surprises comme des after party
dans différents lieux parisiens sinon la
formule est plutôt la même que que les
années précédentes avec plusieurs scènes
des activités au sein du parc
un village food
on va dire les les choses qu'on a qui
ont déjà été installés dans les années
précédentes
sur le vendredi on a notamment l'artiste
Robin Schulz qui qui sera la tête
d'affiche de la yellowstage on a une
scène trans avec deux grandes têtes
d'affichage internationale qui sont
effectivement je connais vini vici qui
avait déjà
fait
headline et la stage yellow il y a
quelques années et qui avait été un des
très gros succès les dernières années
donc on sait on sait on s'est permis de
les réinviter cette année FEDER est
malade le samedi
donc
Federer mala mala c'est le groupe pardon
my French a mis de DJ Snake et FEDER le
DJ connu reconnu de de Nice
on a une capacité de 15000 par jour je
pense qu'on fera on fera à peu près la
capacité sur les deux jours donc on se
on attend 30 000 personnes sur les deux
jours on est on est sur les mêmes cours
que l'année dernière et on avait fait 30
000 l'année dernière donc ça se passe
plutôt bien cette année
[Musique]